[Music]
look at that sheet of flames and that
has happened
within minutes and now it's coming from
both sides
and it's moving this way
[Music]
the mediterranean is on fire
southern europe's most intense heat wave
is fanning the flames
from italy to greece
to turkey
a heat dome which is a high pressure
bubble trapping warmth
might be the complex scientific
explanation
but the hot temperatures the dry
conditions and the strong winds
have resulted in deadly devastation
these are some of europe's most popular
holiday destinations
but this summer they are burning
in turkey water cannon normally used for
crowd control was brought in to tackle
the blaze in bodrum
in sicily the beach resort near catania
had to be evacuated by sea
after more than a hundred people were
trapped
in palermo the smoke could be seen for
miles
flames in greece were being fanned down
the slopes
and at risk of swallowing up seaside
villages
and on evia island temperatures reached
45 degrees celsius
as eu members sent extra firefighting
teams to help
it is an indiscriminate crisis
the turkish president said the wildfires
were started deliberately
and hinted the kurdish separatist
movement the pkk
could be behind them whilst providing no
evidence
and insisting the danger was under
control
our nation should be at ease we will not
allow any of our citizens
to suffer we will cover all the damages
we cannot do anything beyond wishing the
mercy of god for the lives we have lost
but we can replace everything that has
burned
but the calls for calm were largely
ignored
in a week of relentless destruction and
a lot of fear
and while the tourists may be able to
leave it is the people who call this
place home
who are paying the greatest price
something is different
because no i've never had seen this
before we've had little fires before but
i've never seen
this devastation and it's not just here
it's everywhere the infernos swept
through
houses businesses and farmland
terrifying residents
with many claiming this was an avoidable
catastrophe
turkey's leader admitted it was the
worst fire in the country's history
and they had no functioning fire
firefighting fleet of their own
it meant turkey had to wait for
specialized aircraft
from other countries including russia
spain and iran
and despite all the attempts by
authorities at reassurance
even putting out a sophisticated and
stirring video montage of the efforts to
control the wildfires
on the ground those affected were coping
with a very different reality
they've been nearly 200 different fires
sweeping through nearly
half of turkey's provinces and they've
affected
some of the nation's best-known tourist
locations
antalya the country's biggest
international seaside resort
on what's known as the turkish riviera
was hit
as well as the coastal towns of
manafghat
marmarus and bodrum residents and
holidaymakers had to be rescued from
bodrum in a flotilla
as the fire moved on to the nearby
community of chokkaetme
firefighters from istanbul have arrived
just in the nick of time
but they are vastly outnumbered by the
villagers of childhood may who are
desperately trying to halt the flames
laughing at their back gardens
[Music]
many are terrified but this is about
saving their
homes and all their possessions and time
is not on their side
this is quite an extraordinary local
effort these are just
villagers without any training just a
desire to beat back the planes from
their homes
they use water bottles to dampen the
area around their houses
it's all they have but there's another
breakout on the other side of the
village
the fires moving in on them on several
sides
and many villages are bitterly critical
their government wasn't better prepared
i feel very tired and helpless we can't
do
anything our houses are burning
our forests are burning
the state isn't helping if the villagers
weren't here it would be worse
there aren't enough firefighters there
no planes there are no helicopters
where are these people she's screaming
there's growing anger
the help isn't coming quickly enough for
them these fires have gone on for nearly
a week now
where are they where are they
this village is standing in the path of
the fire
and they just can't seem to stop its
advance
these are the worst fires in at least a
decade in turkey with the whole of the
mediterranean suffering higher than
normal temperatures
the fire is completely out running
firefighters it's
totally engulfed at this house and is
taking over and about to burn
tractors and farmland it is outpacing
firefighters
at a rate of knots and they just can't
keep place of it
we saw one farmer desperately throwing
buckets of water around
not nearly enough to staunch this angry
fire
a russian helicopter was helping out
trying to douse the flames
part of the international help offered
after the turkish leader admitted his
air fleet was not adequate
panic is building up and at a rapid rate
the fire is advancing and the winds are
picking up
helping it rip through the surrounding
forest
as the firefighters decide to pull out
they warn everyone to do the same
their plan is to return with
reinforcements but right now the fire's
too strong
and people are scrambling to get to
safety
this is what they're up against because
this has happened within the last 20
minutes
get out get out they're shouting there's
no clarity on exactly how these fires
started although
some have been blamed on arsonists but
the forests are tinder dry after these
record temperatures
and the ferocity of the fires have been
shocking
look at that sheet of flames and that
has happened
within minutes and now it's coming from
both sides
and it's moving this way wow
that is wow turkey has already been
suffering badly economically because of
coronavirus and the fall in tourism
these fires will deliver yet another
cruel punch and they're not over yet
not since the late 1980s has greece felt
heat like this
rhodes is nearest to the turkish coast
right in the danger zone of this burning
summer
skies michelle clifford travelled to the
island and witnessed a separate front
in the battle against the flames in one
case she found a landscape and
livelihood transformed
the withered vines a painful reminder of
what fire delivered to the island
michelle met the vineyard owner now
faced with rebuilding his business
and is everything destroyed in terms of
the vineyards
in terms of the vineyards
i think everything is pretty much
destroyed two generations
of the safiyarakopolis family have
managed this winery
but the intense weather has left them
wondering where they go from here
we're we're thankful that we still have
our home
and our buildings for our business
because the flames came so very close
that
we might have been homeless today so i
guess we're thankful for that
but we do struggle to figure out how
we're going to
recover large swathes of roads have
burned during
days of fires on the island the worst
blazers
ever seen by residents who've lived here
for years
what is the worst heatwave in greece for
more than 30
years brought ministers here with
officials keen to bolster the work of
the emergency services
and deliver a stark warning about why
they think
the extreme weather's unfolding it's
directly to climate change
yes and as you see the temperatures that
greece is experiencing
are quite high but it's not only that we
see these temperatures in north america
all over the world australia we see
wildfires
burning millions of acres
and concerns about rising temperatures
could impact industry on this island
which relies heavily on tourism
the visitors may seek the sun but the
heat has proved too much
for some michelle asked tourists about
their approach to the hotter conditions
it was not good not good a little bit
too hard to be honest
but yeah makes us think also about the
environment
a little bit we'd probably just come at
a different time of year like
october or something they have ways of
uh how to cope with it i wouldn't care
that much
but yeah it's it's getting a little bit
unbearable
one way to cope with the unbearable
heaters with air conditioning but people
were warned to use it as little as
possible to conserve
energy supplies damaged by the fires
piling misery
upon misery
the whir from the skies has become this
summer's soundtrack
as the efforts continue to contain these
unrelenting fires
aircraft have been continually unloading
vast containers of water
onto the still-burning earth below
michelle was with the residents forced
to flee the village of varibobby
as the community was engulfed by fire it
was in
my neighbor's behind field
which i saw the flames were
hi i don't know how much high
it was it wasn't impossible i was i
started crying
i started crying the fire raced through
a mountainous area north of athens with
extraordinary speed
catching residents by surprise and
giving them barely any time to escape
george kiriakopoulos managed to get back
to vary bobby
but just couldn't take in what had
happened to his family land
or the much-loved home of his mother and
father because if you see this in this
situation she will cry his own home was
badly damaged
his dog died in the fire and george was
lucky to escape with his life
came in in 10 minutes included us we're
there
so you were escaping amid the flames yes
yes
inside the flames with emergency workers
the military along with locals doing
what they can are fighting battle after
battle to prevent further damage
hour after exhausting hour they've made
some progress
but this scorched land is unforgiving
and that's what worries ruler mantis
wow so much damage
yes she showed the remains of the
business she runs with her partner
her frustration at the destruction is
huge matched only by admiration for the
firefighters
and worries for the future it's very
hard it's a lot of money we have to
spend
to make this from the beginning
you can't save anything
as you can see hundreds are yet to
return to vari bobby
extraordinary and devastating images
will greet them
and so too will the challenge of trying
to recover
back in turkey the lack of preparedness
has sparked much anger and criticism of
the country's leader
prompting a rash of social media
hashtags calling on other countries to
help
politics is never far away in turkey but
with about a quarter of the country
covered by forest
the nation's been particularly
vulnerable after droughts and record
temperatures
coupled with the lack of firefighting
aircraft
it's been a constant race against the
elements for exhausted firefighting
crews
and two in turkey have died whilst
others were dispatched from istanbul
around 700 kilometers away to boost the
battle force
the fires have ripped through thousands
of hectares of forest
turning trees and farmland into ash
and they aren't done yet
extra firefighters have been called in
to help in the battle along this aegean
coast
the beast of a fire is now heading
towards holiday homes
and a nearby power plant which provides
electricity
to more than half a million people
they're working day and night to cut
scars in the forest and create a fire
break to slow the flames down
bringing in heavy machinery to fell
trees and forge a path to save lives
homes and businesses
helicopters ferried buckets of ocean
water to dump on the flames
over and over again there's been a
visible increase in personnel here
as the fires rampage through
local residents watched aghast at the
unfurling emergency
one week on they're still struggling to
contain the fires
amid some of the highest temperatures on
record
and despite the constant ash raining
down some tourists
pressed on with their holidays a few
hundred meters away on the hill behind
them the inferno was getting dangerously
close to holiday apartments
this is exactly what they've been trying
to prevent the strong winds and
scorching heat are proving a formidable
combination
the scale and strength of these
wildfires are staggering
and keep on getting the better of the
fire crews
it's quite normal well it's more it's
more extreme it's the worst in 40 years
climate is changing
whether it's getting hotter but
and when you look behind you and you you
said it's under control do you think
that's under control
it has been on fire same spot for two
days it's not moving anyway
so we are not bothered with it it's um
well it's let's say
like a you know watch fire it's not
going anywhere
but after a small lull despite their
confidence
just when the exhausted fire crews
thought they'd got it contained
sparks and strong winds set off the
fires again and the crews beat a very
quick retreat
they are proving no match for the
elements and the heat wave and low
humidity is set to continue all week
that's what the fire is left behind
trail
of devastation and the way they've tried
to stop it from
progressing is to build a breaker
they've cut a
a huge scar in this mountain forest
which leads all the way down there and
it's acted as a break
to try and stem the flames and save
that little holiday village which was
standing in the way of the fire
even after the fire passes the danger's
not over
there's so much heat around the flames
often reignite
so surviving foliage needs to be cut
and the embers have to be cooled
firefighters
even those with obvious wounds press on
there's too much to lose and too much to
do
this is a traumatic time for turkey
citizens
and there's a lot of fear as huge
sections of the country go up in smoke
and questions mount on just why the
fires have been so bad
and why the nation wasn't better
prepared for them
as the flames came close to endangering
one of the biggest
coal power stations in muller province
workers were hurriedly taken to safety
by rescue boats
and the nearby town of oren was
evacuated
one turkish television crew was
horrified at the speed of the fire
as they scrambled to get out of the
danger zone
the turkish authorities have struggled
to control the narrative on these
unprecedented events and amidst repeated
images of fires raging out of control
the country's media watchdog issued
warnings to news outlets about
punitive sanctions if they continued to
stir up fear and panic
with reporters criticized for focusing
too much on the actual
fires rather than those put out
turkey's failure to ratify climate
change accords in the face of this
disaster
will add to the international pressure
on the country
but the terrible scenes across multiple
countries in the mediterranean
as fires have ripped through communities
forests and farmland may not be a
one-off
with scientists and weather experts
this may all be repeated next year